[Music]
welcome back to careful boys where we're
hey careful guys i'm pretty careful and
we got ryan today it's me yeah
i'm usually in that dark room over there
i really like how we just like went from
this like diverse group
to just like
asians but then now it's getting like
even more specific asian we're diverse
in here filipino japanese i know but i
want to say big three in filipino
vietnamese no not vietnamese so i got my
first japanese brother over here
i'm gonna squeeze all of y'all out and
it's just gonna be japanese boys it's
gonna come from careful boys to japanese
boys jayboys.com yeah they'll meet me
and nick are gonna start islam boys yeah
yeah we're gonna be island balls i think
wait wait singapore's island right yeah
yeah yeah that's not a white guy oh yeah
i love boys no i've the whole time
that's not a lot guy yeah is it i'm
sitting in a white seat
[Laughter]
where the [ __ ] is steve yeah how do you
guys feel about our diversity card being
gone like we had a uh affirmative action
white guy i do think we need a black guy
on the crew yeah we do so like okay to
replace that and a brownie right because
let's not feel people we are brown all
of us are brown that's not filipino
though it's diverse in the 66 kind of
way we need a latin representative and
we need a black guy you're kind of latin
i'm sort of latin
latin last name you guys use pestles we
got a a geo thing i have a brown sun
yeah yeah oh yeah
what's the combination of yellow and
brown what does that turn into ryan
caramel yeah right curry
what's yellow and brown right anime
so we lost our white card
so now the police can come in any time
they [ __ ] well i'm a veteran some white
oh you're right okay
that's good areas are automatically
white huh automatically yeah that's
pretty cool man and the japanese people
are like
17th generation kind of white so like in
the us as long as my family has been in
basically what ryan's what ryan's pretty
white yeah you didn't even learn
japanese [ __ ] no no my dad doesn't know
guys use your chimney probably too huh
put your firewood in there no we don't
do that we took out the chimney but we
took out the chimney but but my so my
family so my family's got chimneys and
some of those are still functional see
that's white stuff right your great
grandparents meet pocahontas
that was on the east coast come on man
all right wait fifth generation i'm like
not like third or fourth why so how long
how early did they come here
uh before 19 late 1800s
for world war i must have been like
early 1900s at least at least um because
they i mean definitely some family in
camps like for sure
around that time were they kamikaze but
they didn't crash and they were survived
yeah they [ __ ] slid over
they're like oh i've done this in my
country
oh [ __ ] and they stopped there like why
can't i be a citizen
like this is pretty cool
though
if you [ __ ] landed somewhere would
you would you not just be like okay now
like i've got to weigh all my options
here
did they land in
kansas comic con no you know what i
think my is your is your friend is your
family like the first wave of japanese
that came as farmers or like i don't
know about farmers they're def or some
of some are farmers yeah like some of my
family that's up in like central
california like definitely farming roots
um and then my grandfather i think he
was born in like
wyoming or something like that something
were really random but he spent a lot of
time like going back and forth between
like the us and japan and stuff um so he
was actually in
japan when the bombs went off so
so so crazy story about him is that yeah
because he wasn't he was a u.s citizen
in japan
and he couldn't come back no he well he
was there once you're saying he's a
suspect
for [ __ ] like a spy yeah no but he
was when the bombs went off i'm not
saying [ __ ] he got he got he got a free
health care for the rest of his life
because he's part of the civilian
populace that's what it takes to get
[ __ ] free health care so but the only
caveat was he had to go back to japan
for it so he would like fly back and
forth for like the rest of his life to
get free healthcare in japan and to like
visit family and stuff but that was like
something did he feel the earth shake or
how far away i never asked him about
that there's a lot of like dramatic [ __ ]
because he was also an army in the
korean war too so there's a lot of
traumatic american army yeah yeah dude
you gotta ask him no he's dead so
[Laughter]
i did ask him about it one time yeah i'm
surprised the they didn't shoot him like
uh oh friendly fight oh no no you're not
korean so his job was actually he was a
he was a translator because they had uh
defectors that would jump from korea
like uh the north to the south so he
could speak korean no he couldn't speak
korean but some of the koreans could
speak japanese they couldn't speak
english that's right because they they
were colonized by japan so there's a lot
of like crossover there so he would he
would meet up with um defectors he would
translate their korean to japanese or
sorry he would yeah translate the korean
japanese and then they could translate
that to like english and stuff um i
thought it was just the white white
soldiers were so racist back then
they're like hey you speak the ching
chong to him
and honestly they probably would they
probably would do that until he gets
there like yo
or they thought he spoke korean and then
he was like i spoke you speak japanese
and they're just like well that guy
speaks japanese too so like what's the
difference
they're like what exactly and
okay the thing that looks like this yeah
they got the curvy lines and [ __ ] right
yeah you can read it slower so we
understand yeah
you speak scribble don't you
speak scribble
see maybe we can't make these jokes with
steve around
steve i'm so glad he's [ __ ] gone man
because he'll he'll try to jump on and
we'll be like yo steve
you gotta cool with that [ __ ] yeah yeah
yeah yeah what the [ __ ] oh dude i know
he's talking about his proud ass dead
grandpa or whatever
dad that hugs him and gives him love and
stuff yeah
rubbing it in our face you grew up with
love yeah that's why you soft steve so
soft get out of here
dude i told you guys too once he becomes
a [ __ ] crypto billionaire he's pacing
out why do you think he's not here he
kind of called it though yeah he was the
last i guess he kind of is kind of asian
he's caucasian all right so so so since
steve is gone since steve is gone what
other white guy can we get i'm white i
told you i'm the one
we need we need a visually looking white
guy all right what the [ __ ]
i nominate theo vaughn
because he did really well here but he
he kind of he kind of big-timed us
you know what i mean like did he no i'm
just kidding no he needed to bring in
like a really loser guy you know someone
that needs us he's also
cajun which is a little bit different
way he's like oh you're that's spicy
white because
because kate because cajun still gets
beat he's from louisiana yeah yeah yeah
he is yeah he is so we should get him
back we should ask him to come back
because we need someone that can help us
with cop situations cajun people still
so no surfer white because they get
hassled by cops do they yeah they don't
like surfer whites no they don't they
they're nobody
they always yeah so no rainbow sandals
and vulcan right maybe maybe the hippie
white metal militia
yeah he's too good for us so comment
below what kind of whites you guys have
for us you guys have a list we put this
on like craigslist like seeking white
for phil yeah no no no he wants to talk
to the police put it on craigslist o.c
though
orange county that's a better quality
like i mean what did they do for the
minority they they they [ __ ] look for
diversity roles right they go like we're
seeking uh empowered asian male or
whatever that's what we need all i'm
saying is every group of asians needs
one white guy one white guy yeah just
one what about steve's brother he has
two of them that's true nah one of
them's already too rich too right is
there a loser one yeah okay that one
yeah yeah that's cool sister does he
have a hot sister oh we should get his
sister on
he won't be careful boys
yeah a white girl in here whoa
everybody's so good
be careful she says anything all we're
like is like
[Music]
damn steve wasn't you ever told you that
you're hot as [ __ ]
i'm not making the same mistake that i
did before by bringing girls in here
well it's steve's sister though is that
a mistake
was that a mistake no that was actually
pretty good but no it's not i don't know
like i think it's it's good now that
there's no girls you know nobody whites
huh besides steve i know some whites
yeah but are they funny some real ones i
think my buddy matt it's pretty funny i
think what joe's trying to say
you know yeah
there's no girls it's more that we get
to be more of our regular [ __ ] selves
when we feel comfortable as well yeah
well there's girls but then i don't
really consider them girls because
they're so funny that's why you brought
dancers in here right you guys kind of
fit the girl you needed effeminate males
to like balance it out
you guys
talk to you guys like that we're the
source of estrogen
he said it
he hey you know what
we we simp i mean you're not you're not
wrong like yeah
how can i find
i'm not girls but not really girls
dancers that's right
that's [ __ ] how bro
we need one of those guys that you know
they they they're sensitive they like
they kind of listen to women and like
they're they're really like listen to
women they know how they feel and think
and they almost are them
dancers dude dancers they actually
listen to lyrics too dude they have
feelings like
they listen to lips answers dude express
themselves honestly because i'll tell
you this man a dancing man is way more
woman than an engineer woman that's what
i'm saying
oh engineer women
dancing man the dancing man engineer
woman
is way more woman
huh have you seen ninja
i don't know it's a pretty diverse
any engineer
civil engineer woman on here and sit
here next to anthony to see how
polarizing their comments are come on
dude just to see if the effeminate male
dancer is going to match up well see if
he outwoman's her
that part of the casting call
can you outwoman this man
like dave chappelle by definition i'm a
feminist it's like are you smarter than
a fifth grader but it's actually called
are you more woman than a civil engineer
a female civil engineer are you more
woman than anthony lee because that that
what we're saying is anthony lee is the
pinnacle yeah yeah he's as a woman as
you can get and keep my last name out of
it
today's video is brought to you by feels
cbd isn't about what you feel it's about
what you do not feel such as pain stress
and anxiety oh my god my heart this last
week has probably been one of the most
stressful weeks of the year so i deal
with a bunch of black friday stuff and
you know all of a lot of drops we're
still stuck at the ports we got to deal
with that oh we've been working with a
couple of companies to help clean up
some of our internal operations at
barbell
and so we have some big meetings with
something like business [ __ ] yeah some
business [ __ ] and stuff that you know
when things kind of feel like it's
outside of your comfort zone you're kind
of like scared you know yeah cuz i was
doing black friday stuff too but i was
buying
yeah so i'm getting like i'm trying to
get the good deals man and i had to get
everything taken care of before i leave
so i gotta drive here today to shoot jk
news so it's like a time crunch there's
like a deadline
finally got everything done and i was
trying to sleep early because i gotta
wake up early to drive here and i'm like
oh my god i'm so my heart's going
but i gotta sleep by 10. so put some
fields in took a hot bath and i chilled
out and i was able to immediately knock
out within like five minutes once i hit
the bed you are quite the bougie man i
know but that helped me so much because
i felt like i was wired like i drink a
bunch of energy drinks and it's all
thanks to fields because you know what's
pretty awesome about it too
no hangovers
no addictiveness yeah i felt great today
i was sleepless last night i had a
little bit of anxiety but that one all
went away it's a pretty easy process too
you just put a couple of drops in your
tongue but me personally the way i do it
is i make like a hot herbal tea i'm a
boujee [ __ ] myself i put a few drops
there and i sip away
and it's pretty easy um but if you are
intimidated it's your first time you
never know what you're going to get into
you know you don't know how much dose to
take what's cool is they have a hotline
you could call in and they can walk you
through this process and you can be like
yo i'm quite a bougie [ __ ] and joe
likes to put it in tea but i don't know
what i do and they also have a monthly
membership too to make it really easy
because you know the last thing you want
is you're like oh man i'm feeling
stressed out and you open your drawer
like oh no i didn't order it so you have
a monthly membership they can send it to
your house and you save off every single
shipment that's pretty cool so if you
got some anxiety sleepinesses or pain
that you're dealing with and you want to
get rid of it check out feels go to
feels.com off the record don't forget to
use the code off the record because you
get 50 off plus free shipping that's 50
off your first order okay go to
feels.com f e a l s dot com slash off
the record o f f t h e r e c o r d
fields.com off the record to feel good
thank you very much let's face it right
if you even balance dance cruise you got
the quest crew who's a little bit more
guy because there's a break dancer
you know
i know i know because of the hair it's a
more masculine form you have to admit
yeah yeah we're more uh
we're more in touch with there's more
backflips there's more guy moves come on
it's true
yeah now we got to figure out what's
your criteria of a guy dance move a guy
dance move
more brute yeah you know a lot more air
humping it's more athletic ability you
know what i mean
that's cool more more head spin so much
air and nothingness in this conversation
right now that i'm [ __ ] dying you
know these are the important topics and
then in contrast to kenji's what do you
see for kendrick's dancing like a lot of
body [ __ ] waves more body rolls yeah
i mean they might as well twerk at this
point at this point they might as well
just yeah back to steve's sister okay
the real topic here let's just focus on
you're right though okay how many people
big time jk how many how many people got
so [ __ ] big that they left like steve
bobby bobby lee what about davidson what
the [ __ ] they were never they were never
really a part of jk that's true that
whole damn is big i feel like time you
know what we are glazed
do not acknowledge whatsoever
why try not to listen when a woman
speaks
jk dude anthony always gets the [ __ ] out
of the stick jk is the high school job
for entertainers right this is the high
school this is a this is a franchise
right this is double a ball franchise
that's what
the stepping stone like like our buddy
bose she's doing she's like the number
one twitch
scary storyteller right yeah she'll
probably come back i just never invited
her but do you know what i mean like so
people came to jk as a stepping stone
we're like you know i can get way more
successful with scary storytelling or
it's a place where you get a second
chance such as anthony here you know
like it's a it's a place of
you know
his first chance a second chance what
happened to you yeah what what failed
what's this backstory
you know he was at the pinnacle
[Laughter]
and then he lost to his arrival here
and then he said you know what it's but
hey jk news is a place where they could
come
together ironic that we should like find
ourselves here like [ __ ] what was
that like seven years ago it's pretty
crazy though because it's literally
having like tyson and holyfield ending
up in the show wow that's true yeah i
mean they kind of did right they had a
rematch but then
according to you it's more like tyson
and ronda rousey over here okay so if
you could just [ __ ]
can you imagine you guys are at the abdc
right
[ __ ]
worldwide the whole world watches you
can you imagine you imagine being there
like you wore it no no wait wait wait
can you imagine that's like being listen
to ryan's stories and imagine imagine
[Music]
losing would you have thought that in
the future
your you and your arch nemesis would be
sharing
this [ __ ] stage with
this stage
a grander stage that he did i told you
man we're here for the gas money and
food dude
crypto money right jk news i'm just
trying to get some water
can't get anywhere else
i definitely can't afford it on my own
it won't sell to me personally i gotta
do a middle man don't [ __ ] around that's
why i'm [ __ ] here dude i'll show up
steve bounce all right look
this is the real
how successful how rich you got to go
when it's like hey [ __ ] jay candies
we're done me and bart are always here i
know that you guys are disloyal [ __ ]
even if i'm a billionaire i'd probably
be
like metaverse cloning myself talking to
myself
and i could hold a [ __ ] show down by
myself multiple personalities you do
that as a thousand dare
but i will miss you guys because one day
you'll all leave just like all our other
past members or i'll kick you out who
hurt you [ __ ] bro
you'll all leave her i'll kick you
[Laughter]
so staying's not an option no matter
what we become billionaires dude we're
low we're gonna stay here no i'm kicking
you out well the real question he has
said that how much do you have to bottle
on crypto for you nothing yeah tell me
what your disloyal price is
we all know steve me and joe are here
forever yeah so how for you this one
says luna so how did you owe me a meal
a waba grill meal
son of a [ __ ] what are you going to
leave for us for how much does it take
i'll pay you right now get the [ __ ] out
of here i'll test your friendship
get the [ __ ] out of here you buy them
out to go why did you [ __ ] leave we
need a host why am i so poor all the
sudden the [ __ ]
all right you want to get serious let's
get started let's get started you're
[ __ ] serious how much money is ever
gonna make before jk moves to vegas
three thousand
what do you say three three thousand
dollars a year i think it's a money
thing i think it's whenever everyone
feels like it's they can uh make the
decision together
it could be now if everyone's yeah let's
do it all right what if because you know
mortality brings beauty to certain
things
what if we just like officially tell
everybody that like no matter what we
have to end this show in like three
months that you're gonna make say with
suicide packages
oh i like that suicide pact i thought
you could say another poem let me ask
you guys
why are you so selfish because what is
everyone else gonna do for money i'm i'm
i'm [ __ ] rich as [ __ ] and i live in a
garage and i have no expenses you said a
lot of conflicting things
rich [ __ ] and i do this for you guys so
you have a so you have a paycheck you
know what i'll do jk forever as long as
i'm poor obviously because you're
desperate you son of a [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] i was about to say like yeah saying
that yeah i think that's why i'm still
here mr [ __ ] nike shoe over here yeah
you know this guy's at nike shoes
what no
we've had
he owns nike this guy's the [ __ ] face
of nike now yeah he's realized it
the air lee how are you gonna have ramen
noodles how are you gonna have all these
successful things going on and you're a
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] host on just
kidding news yeah
this episode is about steve's sister
what the [ __ ] are we doing all i'm
saying
is steve's gone you're only [ __ ] hope
why are you gonna abandon us why are you
already making plans to abandon us you
son of a [ __ ] you know this right like
they don't like they would i thought you
said you could carry a show by yourself
is anthony your last hope on our lunch
walk [ __ ] nick literally is like yo
i'm trying to host nick i didn't say are
you [ __ ] kidding me nick i never said
that
this one
[Laughter]
i don't know i'll get mad at you guys if
you guys ask me questions let me get mad
at you do an example of how you'd host
uh i'm gonna host this bag of chips
right here okay what do you got back
there what's that uh
cool question okay marine come on
hold on dude mayweather over here dude
question sound it out sound it out it is
on a mission to to make foods you could
this is just a flashback to nick in
elementary school
hooked on phonics dude can't [ __ ]
read you you obviously weren't hooked
never learned i guess
you know what i think i i made a big
mistake and i kicked out too many
members i got to beg them to come back
who would you whose first on list you
would be who's last david
saw you know well you know what
to be honest with you i want to say
nobody but i need them
i don't want i don't want one person one
person anybody you can get who would it
be ah
all right i'll just get steve we need
diversity as well yeah we need diversity
because david doesn't have anything same
color as all of us
yeah that's true he doesn't hit that
quarter he is a korean quarter yeah do
we have a korean quarter you had a
korean
you're three percent wow you're like a
veteran though you know it's like yeah
yeah you know what i like about david
though he's our he's our all-star bench
warmer though we pull him out when we
need him you know but another he makes
some ruckus bro do you need me nope
not right now like checking in he's
calling like daily
hey are you sure you don't need back
this week all right all right
who do you want
to come back yeah you come back yeah
yeah who do you want as like a regular
don't say my [ __ ] ex-girlfriend
either who do you want
say it anthony say it
say it
yeah you already encountered that
yeah it's like which one right yeah
oh god i didn't even know that's what oh
i forgot a lot to choose from
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] they always say uh don't bring
your girlfriends into the company and i
made that mistake many many times
it's not a mistake i'll tell you that
because you know it benefited us in a
great way yeah i would never bring a
single one of them back but bringing all
of them together would be hilarious for
an episode for this [ __ ]
both of them on one episode both of them
one episode all of them just one one
even ones that weren't related to jk
even ones that weren't related and have
them sit there and talk [ __ ] about me
all day oh that's a good episode and
then joe's in the hot seat yeah yes and
they all ask questions all joe's
ex-girlfriend that's a million view
video dude so joe's ex-girlfriends and
steve and then joe's in the hot seat
there's only one that's a million view
video there's only one that i would say
uh i burned a bridge so [ __ ] hard
that if i see their face i would vomit
on myself oh [ __ ] so get a bag dude get
a paper bag i didn't burn the bridge
they burned the bridge it's always their
fault obviously that's the one that has
to be here then sounds like we could
unpack that on a roast
[Music]
you